[Music]
so this is gonna be Tetris in Python
with PI game now this is a pretty
advanced tutorial a lot of the stuff I
do in here assumes that you already have
a basic knowledge of Python and you kind
of know some of the syntax and you're
not a complete beginner that being said
if you are a complete beginner feel free
to watch through see what you might
understand you're probably gonna learn
something along the way it just might be
a little bit confusing because I'm kind
of gonna speed through a few things that
are I would consider like trivial right
now okay so first step for this tutorial
series is you guys have to download and
install Pi game because that's the
module we're gonna be using so I will
put a link in the description and a card
in the top right hand corner here to go
and do that I have a video it's pretty
quick and it kind of goes through any
areas you might run through when
installing PI game so watch that first
and then come back here okay so let just
give a quick preview of what our game is
going to look like so this is Tetris I
didn't go too fancy with the graphics I
pretty much just want to make sure that
we get everything functional here and
then you guys can play around and change
stuff later on if you want to but yeah
this is a fully functioning game you can
see it's just like standard Tetris we
have different colors shapes are falling
down the screen shows us our next shape
and there we go the road just cleared so
that's all I'm going to show you for
right now because I want to get into
actually coding okay
so pretty much what we're gonna be doing
in this first tutorial is we're gonna be
working a bit in the main function we're
gonna be creating the grid we're gonna
be talking about formatting shapes all
the basics of just setting up for the
rest of the tutorials so the first step
and what I need you guys to do is you're
gonna download kind of like a starter
file okay and that's just because if you
see here I scroll through my file I got
a lot of lists I got a few things set up
here and you know what I could go
through and type them all out but that's
just a waste of the video because it
takes a long time so to save yourself
time and to save me some time what I'm
gonna do is just put a link in the
description it's a pastebin link click
that link and download this code it's
just gonna be all this it just has all
the functions that we're gonna need for
this and then it has these shape formats
which I'm going to talk about in just a
minute so go do that if for some reason
paceman is not working let me know in
the comments
and I'll find another way to give it to
you but I'm also gonna put it in the
pinned comment so that you can just copy
and paste it from there as well I do
recommend you check the indentation on
it though because sometimes it messes up
on paste bin and in the comments okay so
now that you've got that downloaded
we're working on that I'm gonna be
working in PI term if you don't know
about PI term don't worry about it you
can just use ID ideally but it's just
gonna save me a bit of time because it
autocompletes variables it does some
cool stuff so that's what I'm gonna be
working in feel free to work in PyCharm
feel free to work in whatever text
editor you want just know that that's
what I'm using it doesn't make a
difference but some of the stuff I do in
here you might not be able to do in
ideally or sublime text or whatever you
guys are gonna use okay so we've got
that all the way we've got everything
set up and now we're ready to actually
start coding and understanding what's
gonna be going on so tetris is a fairly
complex game you have shapes moving down
the screen they're rotating around
they're moving left and right when they
hit the bottom they freeze in whatever
position they're in and then if you have
a full row complete like cubes they're
not real clear and you keep going and
obviously you lose the game if you stack
up too many blocks and it goes up or
above the top of the screen
okay so this first variable is we need
to set up is our screen width and our
screen height so we got eight hundred
seven hundred here the next ones are
play with and play height now this is
the actual red box that you guys saw
that's what these are representing so
since in Tetris we have a ten by twenty
grid we need to make sure that our play
with is exactly half of our play height
so that we have perfect squares right
so doing the math here that makes it 30
width and 30 height per block so that's
our block size of 30 okay so now this
top left and top left X and top left Y
this represents the top left position of
our actual play area that's so when we
start drawing blocks and we start
checking for like collision and stuff
like that we just have these already set
up and we don't have to deal with that
so the math is pretty straightforward
you guys could probably figure that out
you don't need me to explain that okay
shape formats so these and this is the
longest part is why I got you guys to
copy everything is this is what's gonna
represent our shapes in Tetris now you
see that I have multiple lists inside of
lists in most case
says this is because each shape has
possibly more than one rotation right so
this is the standard rotation of the S
shape and that's actually what they're
called in Tetris like S said I oh
whatever
and this is the second rotation and
these are the only two rotations or
whatever that s can have so that's why
we have them in here we have a 5x5 grid
of periods and then whatever there's a
zero that represents where the block
actually exists okay so Zed you can
scroll through you can kind of look at
them and you can see for some of them
for example the square well it doesn't
have any rotation if you flip it it's
gonna look the same so we only have one
list here for jafe however though we
have four right because we can rotate it
in different ways l we also have four t
we have four as well okay after this I
create a list and it just holds all of
my shapes so s said I just so that that
way I can really easily select shapes
just by indexing them in the list like 0
through 6 and shape colors here is the
same thing it just corresponds like for
example if I did shape 0 and I did shape
color 0 then that's gonna be the color
of shape 0 okay same thing with like 6
so shape 6 well color list our shape
colors 6 is the color of that shape so
just makes it really easy we don't have
to deal with dictionaries or anything
like that ok alright so now we've kind
of gone through the like starter file
I'd say and you can scroll down here you
can look at the function names I'm not
gonna explain them because most of them
are pretty straightforward and I'll talk
about them when we start coding them
anyways
but we do have a class here now this
class is gonna be the main kind of data
structure if you want to call it for our
game and this is gonna represent or this
class is going to represent different
pieces so the reason we have the class
is because we're gonna call this a bunch
of times and it's pretty much just gonna
hold the information like X Y width
height for our piece so let's actually
start coding this now so I'm just gonna
create my initialization function or
method and this is actually the only
method that I'm going to have so I need
another underscore just butchered that
and pretty much what this is gonna have
is gonna have an X of Y and then it's
gonna have a shaker okay
and let's see on the information we need
for this and I'll show you why so we'll
say self-thought x equals
self-thought Y is equal to Y self dot
shape is equal to shape and then what
we're gonna do here now is we want the
color and we want the rotation so a self
dot cover well I was already talking
about this self-doubt color is just
equal to whatever the index of this
shape is in this color list so what we
can do is we can do shape under short
colors square brackets and then shapes
dot index and whatever shape we were
given so if we're given the shape s well
let's just find it in the shape list
whatever index that is well that's the
color of our shape pretty
straightforward and then we're gonna do
a rotation so rotation this is going to
be set default to zero and this is so
that whenever we click the up arrow key
we can just add one to this rotation and
that will represent what shape were
actually gonna be showing because again
remember this shape list is a
multi-dimensional list it has you can
see here in this case four lists within
it okay all right create grid I don't
know if we want to do this one yet you
know what actually let's go let's go
ahead and do this one it's not too
complicated so the way that I'm gonna
represent the grid in Tetris so that ten
by twenty grid is just by creating a
list full of colors okay so we're gonna
have a two dimensional list and within
that second dimension it's gonna
represent a bunch of colors okay so I'll
show you just by coding and kind of
talking about after say grid is equal to
and then another square bracket here for
X and range 20 and or I'll explain this
in one second and I will save for X and
range ten okay except here let's go to
zero zero zero okay so what I've just
done here this is pretty this is like
the Python way to create list K list
comprehension we're gonna create one
list for every row in our grid so since
we have 20 rows we want to create 20 sub
lists and each of these like sub lists
or whatever two-dimensional list is
going to have a bunch of colors in it
how many colors is gonna handle it's
going to have ten colors because we have
ten squares in each row
we have 20 rows so that's the way it
works these X's you could replace with
underscores because we don't really care
about the actual variable we just need
to do this that many times now zero zero
zero zero or zero zero zero
yeah I think that's right anyways that's
just black it stands for block and the
way we're gonna draw the grid is simply
by looping through this grid which we're
going to return and just drawing each
color so it makes it pretty
straightforward okay now the only thing
that we have to do here though is we
have this locked position argument now
locked position well right now we've
created a blank grid what if there's
already blocks that have been placed in
our grades like they've already fallen
they're static now they're not moving
well we need to also draw those so to
draw those we're gonna check if any of
the positions in locked position
are not like or whatever positions are
in locked position we're gonna get that
color and we're gonna change the
corresponding value in the grid I'll
show that just by kind of cooking it
here so for I in range undo the length
of grid and again this is gonna give us
20 because the length of grid well that
it's 20 of these right okay so for I in
range Len of grid for J in range and
then we'll say the Len of grid I because
now we're in this list so now we're
gonna do whatever the length of that
list is okay I say if this so if J comma
I because J is our x value I is our Y
value because rows are represented by I
and the columns are represented by J in
locked position and just you know locked
pause it stands for locked position it's
also a dictionary so you can see that
it's a blank dictionary here and each
position so like for example if I had
like 1 1 is gonna be set equal to a
color and the color could be something
like 255 0 0 okay and we're gonna talk
about that and create that later but
that's just somebody needs to know for
now okay so J I in locked position so if
that key exists let's figure out what
that key is so that key is gonna be
equal to well locked position and what
the value is sorry associated with that
key ji now we're gonna change whatever
the current grid position is here so for
grid I
a is equal to C okay I know this might
seem kind of complicated but pretty much
we're just looking through this grid and
we're gonna find the corresponding
position to the locked position and just
change that color in the grid so later
when we draw it we get an accurate grid
okay and you guys will see how this all
is kind of plays out later if it seems a
bit confusing now okay and then we're
gonna return that grid to wherever we're
calling okay so that that's one part
done now we can move down and we can go
into draw window which is then actually
let's do get shape this one's really
easy okay so this is literally a
one-liner return random-dot actually
what is it called here I gotta have a
look
I think it's random dot choose random
duck choice that's where this random dot
choice and then we're gonna be given a
shapeless so say shape actually let's
just I'm gonna cold up here sorry guys
shape random dot choice shapes all this
is gonna do is is gonna pick one of
these shapes and it's just gonna give it
to us so that one we need to create like
a new shape falling down the screen ever
ever that that's all we have to do okay
so get shape random dot choice that
one's really easy okay next one draw a
grid all right so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna be passed a surface and the
surface is obviously what we're gonna be
drawing on so we're gonna start by just
changing the surface surface don't win
service-dog fill with color this case
the color is gonna be black okay sir
just not fill as yours ever do all right
next thing we're gonna do is we're just
gonna draw like a title on the thing so
the way we have to do this we first have
to start by initializing the font
objects when we do that pie game font
dot an it okay this just means we're
setting up font and we're getting ready
to draw to the screen we're gonna create
a font
it's got escape font is equal to PI game
taunt font dot sys capital
SOS font and then we need the font name
I'm the Comic Sans guy so I'm gonna use
that Comic Sans size of the font I
believe ya size of the font Randy's
sixty okay so the way you want to set up
your own font you want to change this
just change this to any font you can
look up fonts on the PI game website
and then just give it a size if you know
the name of the font type it in here it
probably exists in Impa game alright so
now we're gonna need to set up a label
so I say label is equal to font render
and then in here we need the text that
we're gonna render in this case I mean
Cola Tetris you need our anti-aliasing
of one and I believe we need a color in
this case I'm gonna make it white okay
so text anti-aliasing just set this one
I don't know why you need to set this
one but just set it one and then
whatever color you want your label to be
okay now that we've got the label we
need to draw this label on the screen so
lets blend it now when i'm used to
typing when surface double it and then
in this case we're gonna pull it the
label where do we want to put it well
now we want to figure out where the
middle of the screen is so we could just
hard code this in but if we ever want to
change the dimensions of our screen we
want this just automatically kind of
adapt to that so we're gonna do top left
X plus play with / - okay and that's
gonna give us the middle of the screen
if you don't understand that let me know
and I can explain it to you in the
comments down below okay now we're gonna
subtract this sorry this isn't actually
done yet by the width of the label
because this is gonna matter
uh-huh depending on how long that the
label is we it's going to determine
where we place it on the screen so we're
gonna get the width of the label and
we're gonna divide that by two okay so
now we have to do the Y well the Y is
pretty easy we can just statically type
this in because it's from the top of the
screen so I'm just gonna give it and
click 50 is what I typed in 30 okay and
that should put it in the middle the
screen and I can explain that to any of
you guys it might not understand it if
you just leave a comment because I don't
want to waste too much time because I
love people might understand that so for
I in range now the Len of grid because
now we're gonna start drawing all the
great objects onto the screen so we
created a grid we know how that kind of
format works we're going to say for J in
range the Len of grid I same as before
and we're gonna do PI game dot draw dot
rectangle and then this guy's been drawn
the surface and then we're gonna go
career
i J okay and then top underscore left I
need to put this in what do you call it
brackets your top underscore left so
just need to scroll over top left
underscore X plus j x 30 and i'll talk
about this one in just a second how this
works and then top left y + i' x 30
another bracket and there we go now we
just got to deal with this grid thing so
that means that we just now need to past
grid as well into our draw grid okay way
this works we're gonna loop through
every color within our grid so this is
the color grid I J alright this is the
surface we're drawing it on to you and
this is the position in which it's being
drawn now we also just need to add two
things here that I realize I forgot
because we need the XY we need a width
and we need height so for width and
height well that's go to the block size
and block size once again and you know
we can even multiply this instead of by
30 by block size in case we ever decide
to change that so let's do that just to
keep this nice and dynamic and then if
we keep going over here the last thing
we need is a fill so we're just going to
put comma zero to make sure that we fill
in the shape we don't just draw like a
border for it okay way this works we add
our top left X and we're gonna figure
out wherever we are so which column were
in multiply that by block size and
that's our x position same thing works
for the y with the starting Y position
plus whatever row we're in x the block
size will give us the correct position
to draw our Cuban okay after we've done
all that we just need to update the
screen so pygame don't display the
update and there we go so there's
actually one last thing we want to draw
and it's that red rectangle that you
guys saw in that right kind of represent
it like the play area so to draw the a
video pie game dot draw dot rect and
then surface and then in this case we're
just gonna actually let's see here do we
want do I want to dynamically type this
in or do I want to statically draw it so
let's give it a color first of all of
red sea
zero-zero okay and we're actually gonna
type it in dynamic just in case we
decide to change anything later so top
left X and top left Y and then the width
oh we actually already have all these
variables so we have the play underscore
width and you play underscore height and
in this case we're gonna give it a
border size four okay and that's all for
drawing the grid we might come back to
this later but for now that's it okay so
this just draws the actual grid ah draw
a grid and I've added this okay we're
just gonna copy this part of you guys
that says draw a grid so serve first up
lit this label and I'm just gonna move
this in because I realize I have another
function called draw window so in draw
window what I'm gonna do is surface top
fill whatever okay so I take surface and
a grid so I just copied some of it from
there and then instead of updating the
screen here we're gonna update the
screen over here and we're just gonna
call our draw grid
what do you call function like this okay
so now what if we want to draw the grid
and we want to use the same another
program we could just copy and paste
this function we would enough to kind of
take it out of here we have enough like
dissected alright okay subtract rid
again this takes surface and this takes
grid and there we go I believe that's
working well okay now that we've done
that we're gonna start coding in the
main and in main menu and this is what
we're gonna finish off with this
tutorial because I know we're almost at
the 20 minute mark right so what we're
gonna do in Maine now is we're gonna set
up a few variables so the first variable
we need is this locked position locked
positions again and again this is what
we're passing up here in to create grid
it's equal to a blank dictionary just a
set in case we don't pass it then we
don't need it okay so locked positions
equals blank we ready to say grid is now
equal to well create grid because we
already created that function with
locked positions passed to it can't
create a variable called change
underscored piece it's gonna be equal to
false we're gonna make run equal to true
this is just for our while loop that
we're gonna use we're going to say
current piece is equal to get underscore
shape okay we're going to say
next piece is equal to get shape as well
where I set up a clock object and clock
is equal to PI game time dot clock and
we're going to set a variable called
fall time equal to 0 and those are all
the variables that we need in our main
function already coded for us ok so now
we're gonna set up our while loop that's
our main game like you're say well run
first thing we need to do in our loop is
sorry for event in in PI game dot event
dog gets let me say if event dot type
equals equals PI game dot quit well that
means we need to quit the program so the
way that we can do that just simply
hitting run equals false it's gonna
break us out of our raw loop and then we
can deal with that afterwards we're also
gonna add another event this is a
keydown event so if event type egos
equals PI game dot keydown like that
then we're gonna check what specific key
is actually hit so let's go ahead and do
this now I can I get it over with so I'm
just gonna type all the different keys
and then we'll go in and code that after
so we'll say if what do you call it PI
game key equals equals I believe that's
what it is art event key not probably
ended up keep my bad guys event key
equals equals PI game dot K underscore
capital K okay underscore left let me
say if event donkey equals equals PI
game dot K underscore right like that
and then same thing up and down so if
events don't key equals equals I get him
done ok hundreds go down and last one
okay I'm screw up okay okay I don't know
why that keeps happening
okay okay underscore up like that okay
so painfully after typing that left
right down up now we can go in here and
we can kind of code what each of these
is gonna do so if we're hitting left we
want to move our block left if we're
coding right well if we're hitting right
we want to move our block right and
we're going down we're gonna move down
we want to rotate our shape that's what
the main things are gonna do in here so
if we want to move our piece left well
we should change the wat the x value
left wise okay
so the way that we can do that inside
current piece dot X minus equals one now
I know you guys are looking at this
right now you're saying okay well what
what the heck man so current piece is
equal to get shape and that's all it's
equal to get shape well what is get
shape and it's just returning random
choice shapes now this actually just
made me realize the fact that our get
shape thing needs to change a bit that's
because we need to actually create a
piece in here so we set up this lovely
class up here we've already been using
it so piece random dot choice shapes is
the last argument takes it also takes an
x and a y value right so for the X and
the y well the Y is pretty straight
forward is just going to be 0 the X has
to be the middle of the screen so we're
gonna give it 5 and for y we're gonna
give it zero okay
and actually for y we'll leave it 0 for
now but we might want to make it
negative so that it kind of starts above
the screen and then starts falling down
okay
so we have let's make sure this works it
looks right X Y shape yep okay great
okay so that makes sense now on how we
can change this x value same thing for
right I'm gonna do current piece Y dot X
plus equals one like that and for down
we're actually just gonna take this in
for now but this is not exactly what's
gonna work y plus equals one to move
downwards and for up well we need to
rotate the shape so to rotate the shape
this is actually pretty easy over and
each state is current piece rotation
plus equals one okay because when we
change that rotation well that changes
the actual image of the shape okay now
this is all great but the thing is what
if we're moving off the screen or what
if this is not a valid position well
that's why we have a function called
valid space now valid space we haven't
yet coded but I do have it in here
somewhere valid space and what valid
space is gonna do is it's simply in a
return if the current position that
we're in is a valid space so the way
that I do since just make life a lot
easier if we're moving left let's simply
just
change the pieces ex move it left one
and then check if that's a valid
position and if it's not well then we
can just add one and move it back to
where it was so I say if not and then
valid space and valid space again take
two arguments you can take the current
piece it's gonna take the grid okay then
let's just simply subtract or add one to
our piece so all this is saying is we're
gonna move left but if for some reason
moving left results in not a valid space
well let's just add one and pretend like
we didn't even move there so we're not
drawing it we're not changing anything
so this is perfectly fine and it's
actually a really easy way to check
things so they're having two checking if
if it's below this or above this or
whatever okay so now next next one here
gonna say if not valid space and same
thing current piece with grid well now
in here instead of adding one we're
gonna subtract one because we were
trying to move right and there we go
same thing with moving down okay so
we're literally just gonna take the
exact same thing if not valid space
current piece and grid well now let
instead of adding one we're just gonna
subtract one and this is from the Y
value this time so it's like current
piece dot y - equals one okay so now for
up so when we change the rotation we are
changing the shape okay so it doesn't
show this yeah yeah right now like how
we change the shape we're gonna do that
later so we can actually just call the
exact same thing on rotation because
think about it if we're fully on the
right side with like the straight piece
and we try to rotate well that could
result in our piece being moved to the
left or to the right or like there could
be positions where it's on the left or
it's on the right and it's not in the
grid so we do have to check for rotation
if it is a valid space we'll say current
piece and then what else are we doing
great here okay
and then in this case again we'll just
we'll just subtract one from rotation so
minus equals one and that should all
work pretty well okay so after we do
that we're gonna make sure that we
remember to draw the grid so in this
while loop we'll say actually draw
window I'm gonna give it surface
and we're gonna give it grid now this
reminds me that I haven't yet created a
PI game surface that's great so let's do
that
so here I'm gonna say win equals PI game
dot display don't set underscore mode in
this case I'm gonna give it what is
their screen width and screen height so
s width and s underscore height and
that's it for a display you want to give
this a caption though so we'll say a PI
game dot display dot set
underscore caption yep so let's just
call this Tetris like that and now we're
gonna just pass when into our main menu
we'll put one here and then in main menu
we're gonna call me okay and we'll deal
with main menu later I don't feel like
coding it right now and it's not really
important to like the main functionality
of a game so we can simply just do this
okay
main win like this and if I put win here
then everything should work out this has
surface change this to say when in low
cases okay so now you've effectively
done draw a grid or draw window draw a
grid get shape create grid we've created
a piece we've gone through what all this
stuff and the starter file does and we
are now at 27 minutes hey guys and
welcome back to part two of coding
Tetris in Python with Pi game so let's
get right into it
in this video we're gonna be finishing a
few other functions we're gonna be doing
valid space convert shape format we're
gonna be coding a bit in the main and
we're also gonna be fixing a small
mistake I made in the last video so this
code right here in draw a grid yes this
does draw our grid but this is not what
I intended this function to do and I
kind of just realize this when I was
looking over the video and looking over
the codes we're just gonna copy this
code from draw a grid okay delete it out
of there and we're gonna paste it down
here at the bottom of a draw window okay
so now we just have this after we're
bleeding the label we have whatever code
we had within draw a grid okay
because draw a grid would this actually
was supposed to do is draw deep lines
for the grid so I kind of got this mixed
up while I was
going through the tutorial so we're
gonna finish draw a grid now and what
this is gonna do it's gonna draw those
grey lines over top of all of our
different colors so we can kind of see
where each block is that we can see the
actual grid structure so let's get
started with this say SX which stands
for start X is equal to when you call it
top left X okay and then s Phi is equal
to top left Y like that all right and
this is just so I don't have to keep
typing top left X top left Y just makes
it a little bit shorter for us okay now
I'm just gonna say I'm going to set it
before Luke when I say for I in range
and this is gonna be the length of the
grid so how many rows we have let's say
for J in range and this one is now gonna
be a deal n of grid I so how many
columns in each row and then here we're
gonna be drawing lines okay so for every
row we're gonna draw a line so pygame
draw dot line we need a surface give it
a surface we need to cover this case is
gonna be gray so gray color code
standard is 128 128 128 and then we need
two positions okay so the start position
is going to be equal to SX all right and
then sy + what do you call it I I
believe x blocksize and I think that is
actually correct okay now for the end
position well it's gonna be the same
x-value because we're just drawing or
actually it's gonna be let me just check
here yeah it's gonna be a x value that
is just equal to the width so SX plus
whatever to play with this and then the
y value is going to be the same here
because if you think about it we're
gonna be at the same y value each time
we're doing like we're drawing a
horizontal line every horizontal lines
can have the same two Y values and the X
values just gonna be changed okay so I'm
just gonna copy this and paste it in
here now okay uh-oh all right I don't
know why that did that but we'll just go
back like that okay so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna do this K so x
sx plus j x blocksize okay
sy can't actually just stay like this
okay and then for
X same thing s x+ j x block size and js
again as our current column and then
this one s y plus play underscore oops
we need a plus sign here plus play
underscore height like that okay and
that should be drawing us what do you
call it xx vertical lines and then 10
horizontal lines down the screen giving
us a grid and kind of the way that works
is every time we loop through a new row
we're simply changing the Y value of
what line we're drawing and then these X
values are gonna stay static just at the
left side and the right side of the
screen and then the way that we do it
here is we have the X values that
constantly are changing every column and
the y values are staying static being
the top of the screen and the bottom of
the screen to draw the vertical lines
and that's what I wanted to do within
this drunk grid function so now that's
all kind of sorted out and we fixed like
a small mistake don't get me wrong you
can still have that other code up here
it still works fine but just in terms of
what I actually wanted to do with these
functions that's the way we needed to
fix it okay so now that we've done that
what I want to start doing is getting
into this convert shape format okay now
this is probably the most complicated
function I want to say within our
program and what this is going to take
as an argument or a parameter is just
the shape now this is what I was talking
about before so when we have a shape it
looks something like this right so we
have zeros that we have periods now this
looks nice to us like we can tell what
kind of shape this is but the computer
has no idea so how can we get this into
a form that the computer can read and
ideally want to give it we want it to
give us positions within the grid of
where blocks exist and then we're not
going to give position if the block
doesn't exist so if there's a period
like this okay and you'll see what I
mean as we start coding this function
and that's what the goal is function is
to do to take that information and put
it into something that's actually useful
to us so we want a bunch of positions
that's the goal because from these like
lists we want to generate a list of
positions and then based on those
positions we can do things we can check
them we can draw them and so on so I'm
just gonna create a list called format
don't worry if it's a keyword
it'll just override it we're gonna say
when we're giving a shape we're actually
given a piece object
so I don't know why I'm calling shape
but whatever it's fine so shape dot
shape and then we can just do is equal
to and I'll talk about this in a second
shape dot rotation modulus the length of
shape dot shape
okay so what this does is actually gives
us the sub list that we need so needs to
be spelled correctly I don't know how I
butcher that so bad okay shape touch
shape so if we look again here whenever
we're passed a shape we're actually
passed something like this right
surpassed the shape object and its shape
property so right here is look something
like this looks like the variable T
which would have a list full of lists so
we want to get the actual sub list so
which one this list right that's the one
we want so the way we do that is by
getting the shape rotation modulus the
length of the shape so for example if
our current rotation is zero like we
haven't rotated yet then what's gonna
happen is we're gonna have zero modulus
the length of shape in this case the
length would be four so we get zero so
we're given this first shape now if we
have one we're given this if we have two
or given this if we have three were
given this and if we have four then we
go back and we get this one okay and it
just keeps going and keeps going because
modulus simply just gives us the
remainder so that's how we can tell what
the actual current shape is within that
main list okay hope that makes sense so
now that we've done that what we're
going to do is want to set up a loop and
because we want to look through every
row and every column and then based on
if there's a zero or a period we're
gonna do something so we're gonna say 4i
comma and because we want the line as
well in enumerate right and then format
okay because format is the list that
contains like the actual zeros in once
okay we're just gonna say Rho is equal
to list of line this just gives us a
nice list format that we can deal with
making it easier for us I'm gonna say
for J in or J comma column sorry in
enumerate and now row so now every row
we're getting the current line and then
we're going to loop through the line and
look for either a zero or a period I'm
going to say if column which is going to
be
for example if we have some like this
it's gonna look like zero zero okay so
this is what our row is gonna look like
so when we start looping J will be zero
and column will be a period okay just
just in case you're kind of confused
there okay so before
if column equals equals and it's gonna
be string zero then we know that we've
hit like a position like this cube
exists here so what we want to do is
want to add the position to our
positions list now it's not so simple as
just add the current I and J value we
actually have to add something else I'll
show you right now I'm just gonna type
it out and kind of talk about okay so
shape dot X plus J and then shape dot y
plus I okay so this is our x value it's
the current value of the shape because
if the shape is already moving down the
screen or moving left and right well we
need to add that to whatever the J value
is whatever column were in within this
list okay and then same thing for with
the Y value so whatever the current Y
value is of our shape we're gonna add
whatever column or whatever row sorry
we're now in as for the Y value okay and
that is the positions that we need in
these positions list okay so now that
we've done that we just have to modify
these positions slightly we just have to
give them an offset okay and I'll talk
about why this allows you to do this so
for I pause in enumerate positions okay
then we're going to say positions I is
equal to and then it's gonna be the
current position okay so we just need to
put this in a tuple cuz that's way we're
gonna give it pause 0 minus 2 and pause
1 minus 4 okay so now let's break this
down and kind of talk about exactly
what's going on so we started off blank
list positions we're just getting the
actual shape within this list so for
example we get something like this okay
and then we're looping through it and
where am i sorry and we're pretty much
just checking if a 0 exists in each
position of that shape okay if that
exists then we're gonna add that
position into our list and the way we do
that is simply by getting
the X plus whatever the current column
is that we're looping through and
whatever the current row is plus y okay
now that we've got that the issue is
that if we look here we're gonna get
something like for a position list here
we'll get something like 3 1 and then
we'll get 3 2 we've got 3 3 and we'll
get 3 4 ok now the issue with that is
we're adding the current X value plus
these two periods and the O so we need
to remove these kind of trailing periods
right because that's gonna result in our
positions being offset it to the right
by 2 much same thing with these Y values
okay because when we're counting this
row we're saying well this is 1 lower
than this row so our current Y value say
it was 0 and we're adding to it
now instead of just adding 1 we're gonna
be adding 2 so what's gonna everything's
gonna be offset down so the way that we
can kind of fix this is just by
offsetting by constant by offsetting I'm
just gonna take every x value that we've
added and subtract 2 from it and every Y
value that we've added and subtract 4
from it now what this is gonna do is
simply just move everything to the left
and up so that when we are displaying it
it's just more accurate to the screen
okay you guys can see what's gonna
happen if you don't offset this and
you'll notice that you kind of run into
a few errors so just run with me on this
area and just kind of you should see how
this works later on ok ok so now that
we've converted this shape format I want
to go in code valid space now okay so
valid space is gonna take two parameters
shape and grid all right now we're gonna
check the grid to see if we're moving
into a valid space so what I'm gonna do
here is I'm going to create two liske
I'm gonna say accepted how do you spell
accepted accepted underscore pause so
these are just gonna be the positions
that are actually valid okay is equal to
and just flow with me on this we'll talk
about in a second for J I and then
within this list for J in range 10
system Li what we did in the last
tutorial and then for I in range 20 okay
so this is really similar to the way
that we created the grid we're just
getting every single possible position
for a 10 by 20 grid okay and we're just
adding it in a tupple in accepted
position it's gay that's great but the
thing is I want to convert this into a 1
dimensional list so this is the way we
can do this and make other positions but
now how do we flatten this list so this
is actually how you do this okay so
accept it cause it's gonna be equal to
and this is one way there's many J for
sub in accepted positions and then one
more for J in sub okay so what this is
actually doing now is it's pretty much
taking all the positions in our list and
just adding it into a one dimensional
list and we're just overriding this list
with that so see if you guys can
understand that if not don't worry about
it just know that all this does is
simply flatten this list so we go from
looking something like this we wouldn't
call it like 0 1 and then having another
list embedded just trying to show an
example here 2 3
so we go from that to something that
kind of looks like this and we just have
two positions in it now so we don't have
those sub lists and this just makes it a
lot easier to loop through ok so now we
just have 0 1 2 3 rather than having
these embedded lists full of other
tuples ok that's all we're doing with
this line ok so after we do that what we
want to do is we want to get all these
positions um and we're gonna get the
shape and we're gonna convert it into
our positions right because remember
whenever we get a shape it looks
something like this it means nothing to
us we need to first convert it into
positions before we can compare it
against other positions in our grid so
we're gonna use this convert shape
format grid our convert shape format
we're gonna pass it to the shape and
we're just gonna store this in a
variable and I guess we're gonna call it
what should we call it formatted okay
because I guess that makes sense we
formatted our shape so now we can use
this and kind of compare it against
accepted positions so here we're gonna
have a list that looks like something
with a bunch of positions in it and then
this one we're gonna have a list that
has a bunch of positions in it so you
might see where we're going here in
terms of how to compare these things ok
ok so now that we've done that we've
kind of got all our data ready to check
this is the really easy part where I'm
just going to say for position in format
it and all we're gonna do now is just
check if this position exists within
excepted positions because accepted
position is every position that were
allowed to have right so we're say if
paws not in accepted position and this
is an important part pause one is
greater than a negative one return false
and then otherwise so if we make it
through that loop that means we had all
our positions accepted we can return
true okay so let's talk about this
really quickly the reason I have this if
pause once the Y value is greater than
negative one is because when we give
this offset of four what ends up
happening is we get some when we spawn
in our shapes they're gonna spawn above
the screen and then we actually want
this because we don't want our shape to
show up on the screen we want to start
falling before it's actually seen so
typically this means a Y position is
going to start out like negative 1 or
negative 2 so the thing is while it's
falling we're checking if it's in a
valid position right but the thing is
it's not going to be in a valid position
if it's negative so we just want to make
sure that we're only asking if it's in a
valid position if the y value is greater
than negative 1 so greater than or equal
to 0 okay and this is a really easy way
to tell us well are we on the grid or
not so let's give an example say we're
trying to move left and we're already at
the edge of the screen so that means
we're gonna have an x value of negative
1
well that position of negative 1
whatever Y value is not going to be in
this accepted position great way to code
list so when we try this we're gonna
return false and it's not going to allow
us to move left and that is the whole
point of that and now okay
what am I doing here ok so I also just
want to modify this part up here so I
haven't for ji and range for J and range
if I in range 20 I want to just change
something here okay so what I'm gonna do
actually let me say if grid I J equals
equals and then the color 0 0 0 okay so
this is an important part I was kind of
waiting I was kind of thinking about
this so pretty much we're only gonna add
this position into our accepted position
if it's empty which actually makes a lot
of sense because think about it if we
already have a color
in that position then that's not a valid
position we can't move into where a
piece already exists so what this
conduct condition does it says okay
we're only adding this position now if
this is true so if IJ is true then /
code we can add the position if it's not
zero zero zero that means something
exists in there so that's why we're not
gonna add it into our excepted positions
okay so I know this looks kind of
confusing so I'm doing like a bunch of
embed in for loops this just saves us a
few lines it's kind of a cool way to
create a list in one-liner it's like the
Python anyway so I figured I'd do that
for most of the stuff in here okay so
now that we've done that what else can
we code well you know what while we're
here we can code check lost all right
this one's a really easy function this
is just simply going to check if any of
the positions are what do you call it
above the screen so if we hit Y value
zero then we know that we're above the
screen and we've actually lost so the
way to do this very site for pause be in
positions because what this is gonna do
is we're gonna pass a list of positions
so we're gonna get every pause now in
the position we're going to say X Y is
equal to pause which simply you're
splitting up the tupple because we know
we're gonna get something looks in the
form of like three four okay and we're
gonna say if Y is less than one so equal
to zero or greater then we return true
else okay we don't even need no say
return false down here so if every
position is less than or greater than Y
or whatever one then we will return
false because we haven't lost yet
otherwise we return true okay so we're
almost getting there now I want to go
down to the mean and I want to finish
coding up some stuff in here so last
time we kind of just left it at this
like moving pieces around whatever but
we have these variables okay so change
piece next piece o'clock fall time that
we're not using so what I'm gonna do now
is I'm going to show you guys how we can
actually move our shape down our screen
at like a regular time interval so I'm
gonna create a variable here actually
called false speed and this is how long
it's going to take before each shape
starts falling okay
so we'll talk about how to do this I'm
gonna start coding it now so pretty much
we're gonna say up here and I didn't do
this before which fall along grid equals
create grid based on locked positions
the reason we're doing this I know we
already created grid up here is because
every time that we move we have a chance
to be adding something to locked
positions we're gonna do that later
because for example if we hit the bottom
of the screen will now lock the position
it's gonna be equal to something else
because it's gonna have a new shape in
it shouldn't we need to constantly
update the grid so that when we're
drawing it to the screen we get like an
updated version so that's why I'm doing
that up here okay I also need to
actually I don't think I need to do that
here we need to add to fall time okay so
the way we're gonna add to fall time
because this is gonna track would he
call it how long since like the last
loop ran is by using this clock object
that I set up here okay so before I add
to that after here I'm gonna do clock
dot tick and then I'm going to add this
and I'll talk about this after I do it
so clock get underscore raw time like
that okay so the way that this works is
this wrong time actually gets the amount
of time since this last clock tick so
when I first add it's gonna be zero
because we haven't yet ticked the clock
and the next iteration it's gonna see
how long it took this while loop to run
and then it's going to simply add that
amount okay so it's actually going to
give us real time this means this should
technically run at the exact same speed
on everyone's computer in every one
machine because I know when I use fps
FPS is dependent on kind of the speed of
what do you call it on your actual
computer sometimes like the way I did it
in other games so this is a better way
to do it
so now what I'm gonna do is since I've
now incremented the fall time and this
is gonna be given to us in milliseconds
so like one second would be a thousand
that's that number and our fall speed is
in well zero point two seven so what I
need to do is I have to say if fall time
divided by a thousand is greater than
false speed then we're going to do is
really reset fall time equal to zero and
if we're going to add one to the current
Y value so
which means we're script we're moving
down the piece one so this is gonna
automatically now move our piece down
another thing is what if our piece will
hit the bottom the screen or what if
it's moving into position we can't move
into so this is the same thing we've
kind of done in here what we're gonna do
is going to say again if not valid
position or valid space whatever
given the current piece and our grid I
believe at least grid okay then and
actually we're gonna check one other
condition and our current piece dot y is
greater than zero this means that we're
not at like the top of the screen
because the same thing with negative
values all right is greater than zero
then what we're gonna do is were gonna
subtract one from the current piece so y
minus equal one because that means will
we moved into an invalid position so
let's move back up one and pretend like
that never happened and we're just gonna
say change piece is equal to true now
the reason I'm setting change piece
equal to true because think of it right
if we're moving down and we move into
position that's not valid well we know
we didn't move left or right off the
screen because we were moving down that
means we must have either hit the bottom
of the screen or hit another piece so in
that instance we need to stop moving
this piece and we need to change it and
what changing piece is gonna do we're
gonna do that later is simply gonna lock
all the positions what they're currently
in and then it's gonna make this next
piece generate down the screen and I'll
show you that in a second but this is
kind of the way to check it and it's the
easier way then you don't have to check
like the Y values and and all that stuff
okay alright so now that we've done that
let's move down here to the bottom of
main and let's start adding a few things
ok so what I want to do down here now I
want to say shape positions so shape
underscore pause is equal to convert
shape format current piece because what
we're gonna do now is we're going to
check all the positions of the piece
moving down to see if what we've hit the
ground or see if we need to lock it okay
so and we're gonna add all that color to
the grid so that when we're drawing it
we actually see the piece cuz right now
we have the piece but we don't add its
color into the grid so we're not
actually gonna see it show up so I mean
first need to add it to the grid so we
can draw it and we can see it moving so
to do that we're gonna say for I and
range the blend of shape positions okay
we're going to here going to say XY
equals shape positions of Ikes that's
the current iteration the current one
we're looking through and say if Y is
greater than negative one so this means
that we're not above the screen then we
say grid Y x equals current piece dot
color okay because remember the grid
stores a bunch of different colors so
while we're doing the greatest giving
different colors and based on that
position in the grid so Y X which is
going to be this shape the all the shape
positions we're gonna draw that color
now the reason I'm gonna have this
negative one is because imagine that
we're at the top of the screen and we
try to draw it or we're above the screen
we have a position with a negative Y
value so if we throw negative we're not
actually gonna get an error in grid here
but it's gonna end up looking like it's
at the bottom of the screen and then
moving to the top and it's just gonna
look weird if you guys want to see what
it looks like this just removed this
condition and you'll see that why I
haven't added in okay so now what we're
gonna do is we're gonna check this
change piece variable so I put it up
here change piece this means that we've
hit the bottom or we've hit something
what we're gonna do now is we're gonna
update locked positions and this one I'm
gonna start talking about locked
positions okay so for pause actually in
shape positions all right we're going to
say P is equal to posi row pause one
alright I don't know why I do this but I
think there's a reason for it so let's
just run with it
and when I said locked positions P is
equal to current piece don't covered
okay so what is this well locked
positions is gonna be a dictionary in a
form like this right it's gonna have a
top one here that's gonna have a
positions like 1 2 : and then we're
gonna have a color and the color is
gonna be another tuple but RGB values
okay so for example to 5500 the reason
we have this is so that when we past
locked positions into our grid like this
right we can get each of those positions
in the grid and then update the color of
great so every time that we have like a
locked position in a locked position as
simply means our piece is no longer
moving it's hit the bottom of the screen
and we're on to a new piece we can get
the position and we can get the color
and then we can update the grid based on
that and we can keep that in there okay
and that's the way that locked position
works so it's a dictionary with the key
of a position and the value of a color
all right that's kind of like the data
structure for now what we're gonna do
after this after we update our locked
positions and we add positions to it
when I say current piece equals next
piece okay so we're just gonna change
that and now since we've said current
piece is now equal the next piece what
we need to update next piece so let's
get a new shape because we're just
moving forward with the game and now of
course we got to say change piece equals
false because we're on to a new piece
that's gonna spawn at the top of the
screen okay
and I think that is about it what we
also want to do actually is we're gonna
check if we lost the game and I think I
do this after the draw window I don't
think it really matters but where should
I say if check lost based on what do you
call it locked positions okay
so these are all the positions of the
shapes then we're gonna say run is equal
to false and that's gonna break us out
of this wall up and you know what while
we're here let's indent out nope I game
dot what is it I think it's not display
doc quit or something yeah don't display
dot quit so we're actually just exiting
out of our game now up until this point
I actually have not tested my code now I
know some of you probably think I'm
insane because we've already written
like three enter lines of code we
haven't tested any of it the reason I
haven't done this is because I wanted to
test this in between videos figure out
what the errors were so that I didn't
waste too much time fixing all of them
so I'm gonna go through a few errors
that we have now and show you what
happens when I run the code so I'm just
complete that cuz that was the fix that
I made and pretty much you can see it'll
be crashed right away and we actually
get a 4-iron range
none type has no length now the reason
we get this and this happens down in the
main it's because in convert shaped
formats somehow I managed to forget to
return position
this is really important because the
whole goal of this function well was to
generate this list of positions and we
did that fine but we forgot to return
them so uh pretty easy error to fix or
return positions now again we run this
way ok everything looks good no there's
another issue all right so just watch if
I try to go off the screen you can see
that we get a unsupported operant for
current piece because I forgot to put a
Y or an X here so let's go down to main
let's fix this what line are we on 260
to 262 current px yeah that would be
important okay now I know there's a few
other errors so this one current piece
mimes equals let's change this to an X
current piece - equals wow I really
messed up on this a lot ok dot rotation
minus equal 1 okay so this is rotation
and let's see anything else let's run
the program see ok we're getting another
issue here so if we have valid
spacecraft ok so I just messed up and a
bracket here so let's go
lying 265 here we are so we're gonna
take this quotation mark or what I'm
saying edition might bracket and just
put it there and all should be good now
let's see we go down to the bottom the
screen ok we got another and let's just
play this for one sec see if we can run
into any errors
okay so we're rotating fine we can't
move off the screen and all looks to be
doing ok all right so that's a good sign
for now let's leave that so it doesn't
look like there's any issues if you find
any I'd probably end up fixing them in
future videos so don't stress about it
ok so now that we've done all this what
we need to do next is a few things
alright so we need to deal with this
draw next shape clear rows draw text
middle what other functions to have and
I think that's about it and we're also
gonna deal with main menu kind of
starting the game finishing the game and
all that stuff so what I first want to
do actually is I want to deal with draw
next shape then I'm gonna do clear roads
just cuz clear rows is kind of
complicated so draw next shape what this
is gonna do is they're just gonna draw
the next shape kind of off the screen
and show us what it is because in
tetris typically it shows you like the
next shape the next few shapes so yeah
now this seems pretty straightforward
like just draw the shape it's actually
kind of long because we have to once
again get this list turn it into
positions that we can use and yeah it
just it gets a bit complicated so what
we're going to do is we're also gonna
set up a font in here it's gonna say
font equals PI game thought font dot sys
font here we're gonna do Comic Sans
again because you guys know I love Comic
Sans Comic Sans sighs stick 30 and let's
render this font okay so label equals
font don't render text for this is gonna
be next shape okay feel free to add a
colon or something if you guys want
anti-aliasing one text color white 255
to productivity feel okay basically
already been through that okay now we
need to figure out where we're gonna
draw this this label okay so let's see
the same thing we've done before you say
s X is equal to top left X plus the play
width and I'm going to say s Y is equal
to top left Y plus the play underscore
Heights actually I'm gonna play a
hundred we're gonna say play height
divided by two okay now what we're gonna
do is this is gonna give us like to the
right maybe I can just run this and show
you guys it's gonna give us where my
mouse is right here like a position kind
of similar to here so we are actually
here so what we want to do is we want to
add a constant to this so we move to the
right a bit so this constant we're just
gonna hard code in and we can change
this and play with it if we want it to
be like moved more to the right or more
to the left so to move more to the right
rear now add 50 and then to kind of make
this look a little bit better where you
can actually subtract a hundred from the
site so we can move a bit higher up on
the screen play with these constants if
you guys want it to look a bit different
okay so now we've got that what we're
going to do is we're gonna once again
we're gonna format are in say format is
equal to shape.com thing we need the
actual shape so not just like that mean
a shape talk rotation modulus the length
of shape dot shaped like that okay so
this is the exact same thing that we did
in format whatever you guys know is know
what function I'm talking about and I've
lost myself here okay just to get the
actual like sub list that we need okay
so now on you might say well what do you
what are you doing here we already have
like a function that does this for us
don't worry about it just follow along
because this is a bit different the way
that I'm gonna do think a so I'm gonna
say for I comma line in enumerate all
right
and then row or actually before I'm not
sorry I'm gonna do the same thing here
we're gonna convert row it into list is
really similar to the other function
except we're going to do one major
change and you'll see that for row
equals list line we're gonna say for J
comma what do you want to call it column
in enumerate row this time and exact
same condition if column equals equals
zero what we're gonna do here instead of
adding some position to list is we're
gonna draw something and this is why I
didn't want to use the other function
that gives us list of positions because
I don't care about the position within
the grid I just care when we should draw
something or not because this doesn't
matter it's not gonna be moving we just
want to draw like a constant image on
the right side of this or a static image
on the right side of the screen that we
can just look at okay so what we do here
is we're gonna say pygame draw rect so
don't draw rect I need surface we pass
the surface in we need a color it's
gonna be the shape color okay and then
we need our position of drawings for SX
and then in this case we're gonna have
to since we're drawing each cube right
we're not dressed drawing the whole
shape plus J multiply it by 30 and then
we're gonna do the same thing with y so
sy + I multiplied by 30 and we actually
just changed this to let's change the
block size to be a bit more dynamic okay
so it's a 30 block so it's just in case
we decide to change the dimensions of
our screen later on and then we new
width and height and that is gonna be a
block size and block size and we want
this filled in so comma 0 okay so what
we've done here is really similar to
what we've already done
we're just gonna be drawing these blocks
according to where they show up like in
this list based on the initial
exposition plus like a changed kind of
position or whatever okay anyways I
think that's about it for this oh we
need to actually
blitt the label now so we created this
label we have actually drawn on the
screen yet so let's do this so we say
surface dot bullets label change this to
a period okay and then we need a
position what's our position going to be
well we're actually going to SX plus 10
and sy minus 30 okay again play around
with these constants guys if you want
your thing to look a bit different be
more centered whatever I again I don't
go like too crazy on cosmetics here I
just want everything to work and look
decent I assume you guys can mess around
that I right okay so now we've done that
we've drawn the next shape well we
actually need to call this function so
within draw window we're gonna call draw
next shape as well so where should we
call this let's see what's called before
we draw a grid draw an X shape or
actually we can't call it in here where
we need to call this in the main because
we only have next shape within the main
symbol right when we're drawing draw
window we're actually just gonna call
draw next shape because we need to give
it the next shape so it's gonna be next
piece and then the grid does that it
takes it takes a surface yeah surface
okay so let me just go check this to
make sure and our surface is not called
surfaces it it's called win okay so in
draw next shape you haven't take a pen
surface okay so that that should work
fine you know what let's actually just
test this now and see this working and
we're not showing up we're not drawing
this surface hmm I believe it is because
ah draw a windowed Renick [ __ ] okay so
what we need to do actually it's this
draw next shape we're gonna draw after
draw it now and we're just gonna update
the display in here so pygame dot
disability dot update and then if we go
to draw window just remove this display
update and this should work
there we go so now we're getting next
shape on the side the reason that wasn't
working is because we were pretty much
drawn over top of the next shape every
time that we drew the window so now
that's working fine we have our next
shape showing up and what else do we
need to do I'm really delaying trying to
go to this clear rose function because
it's really complicated but I think
we're gonna have to do this next okay so
clear rose and tetris obviously if we
create a full row we need to clear that
row and then so that's the only way the
user can win obviously yeah so the way
to do this is probably a lot easier than
the way I'm gonna do it but try to
follow along because this is the only
way I could kind of get to work and this
is probably the hardest part of the
actual game okay so we're gonna take
grid we're going to take locked
positions and we're going to do is we're
gonna set up a few things here just
follow along if they'll try to explain
as I go so I'm gonna say Inc which is an
increment 0 for I in range the Len of
grid negative 1 negative 1 ok and we're
actually just going to subtract 1 from
this to what this is gonna do is go loop
through our grid backwards so it's going
to start at the twentieth row and it's
gonna move up to the nineteenth row okay
I'm gonna say the current row is equal
to grid I all right now we're going to
say if the color zero zero zero is not
in our row let's clear okay so we're
gonna add one to ink don't worry I'm
gonna explain this after that just
follow along okay say IND equals I I'm
going to say for J in range the length
of row what we're gonna do is we're
gonna try to delete locked square
brackets current position there's gonna
be J I and then if this doesn't work and
I accept and continue okay okay so let's
just talk about what I just did here
because I kind of went fast and there's
another part of this function door so
the way this is gonna work these we're
gonna say we're gonna look through the
grid backwards we're gonna set row equal
to every bulb row in
agreed so what that really pig do and
the way that we know if the bro should
be cleared is if zero zero zero doesn't
exists because if zero zero zero to
success that means there's no plaque
squares in our row which means it's
completely filled with shapes are
completely filled with cube objects or
whatever okay
so we know we can clear it so the way to
clear it now and don't worry about these
variables I'll talk about that a second
is to get every position in that rail to
do that we need to loop through J in the
row and we're already out the current
row so we know that I is just gonna stay
static change J and try to delete this
from locked positions because now what
we're doing is the locked positions need
to be removed
so when mandela bees since locked
position is a dictionary and it's
mutable we can I should just change it
within here and that's how we delete
those keys and those colors from the
grid okay so after we delete that all
what we need to do is we need to shift
every row so what's happening now and I
think I'm actually just gonna pull out a
little I have a drawing tablet and just
start using this to kind of explain some
things because it's pretty complex so
just give me one second all right so
what we need to do is we need to shift
every row so if we delete like a the
bottom row we every rule above that row
needs to move down by one so if I go to
let's see this and delete this okay so
you can see if I have a grid alright and
it looks something like this we're just
gonna do like a very basic like 3x3 grid
okay just to save us some time let's say
that we want to clear this road down
here so these are full of colors right
so if we clear this row and what happens
is we get rid of all these and that any
positions that were above it so let's
draw something like this now this is
here well currently this is floating
right because if we've cleared all these
positions down here so we got rid of
those this is floating so this needs to
move down one so how can we go about
doing that and the thing is every other
row needs to shift down by one as well
but now let's talk about like a
potential issue we might run into so if
I delete all that and let's say we have
a grid that looks like this okay and
there's a color here if we delete this
row the grid actually now in our memory
only looks like this all right it's only
this top portion
because we've deleted an entire row out
of the grid so yeah we can shift
everything down by one but now we're
left with the grid that's one less than
the other one so what we want to do is
you need to add another row at the top
here so that our grid stays the same
size because if you delete an entire row
well you're deleting row right so you
need to add back the other positions at
the top because everything's shifting
down by one so really the way it works
is you delete this and then this whole
thing moves down and then you add a row
at a talk like this okay so that you're
back to your continual grid I hope that
makes sense that's kind of the only way
I can really explain it to you guys in
terms of how we shift things and I mean
to do it in code right okay so leave a
comment if you guys confused about that
cuz I'll try to explain it in a better
way but it's just kind of like a
confusing topic in general okay so now
we're gonna do say if I NC is greater
than zero okay we're going to say so
this means that we've shifted and we've
removed at least one row and I'll talk
about the case in which we moved two
rows in one second okay
let's say four key in and just follow
what this is this is gonna be kind of
confusing list of locked positions so
locked because we're just we just pass
in Lock there okay and then when you say
key because lambda I'll explain what
this does in a second x x-1 and I think
that's about it and we're actually just
gonna reverse this negative okay
so for every key in our sorted list of
locked positions based on the Y value is
what this does so given a list that
looks like this if you have like zero
one zero zero okay give it a this a very
basic list this could be a of locked
positions list okay what we're gonna do
is want to sort this list and the way we
sort it is based on this number here
this Y value and this is what this key
equals lambda x x-1 does you don't have
to understand that this is just a really
kind of complex way to sort of list what
we're gonna do is we're gonna now make
it look like this is your zero
zero-one the way we do that is so that
we get all the positions that have the
same y value in like the correct order
okay and you'll see why we need that
when we start coding
okay so I'm gonna say X y equals key
because you can remember key is a tupple
and I'm gonna say if Y is less than I
and D we're gonna say new key is equal
to X comma y plus AMC and then locked
new key equals lock dot pop key okay
let's dissect this now alright because
this is I told you guys this was kind of
confusing so what we're doing now if we
want to shift every single position in
the grid down because when we delete a
row everything above that needs to move
down so the first part is pretty
straightforward okay so XY equals key so
we're simply getting the x and y
position of each key in locked positions
and remember locked positions as a key
and then a corresponding with that is a
color okay straightforward now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say if Y
is less than int and what that means is
if Y is if the Y value of our key is
above the current index of the row that
we removed so if we remove for example
row 17 then only things that are above
that are gonna move down we don't need
to move anything below row 17 down
because we didn't remove anything after
row 17 right and I'm gonna show this in
a drawing in just a second okay so if
that happens what we're gonna do is
we're gonna change a key we're gonna get
a new key we say it's igloo the current
x value but we're gonna increment this
by a certain value so we're gonna add I
had to the Y value to shift it down and
then we're gonna do is we're going to
rewrite we're gonna create a new key in
locked position which gonna have the
same color value as the last key B on
this one this gives us the lost current
color value but it's equal to this
position right so I'll explain why this
works now kind of withdrawing and why I
needed to look at this backwards okay
because when we're looking at from
bottom to top there's there's a reason
for that
alright and I might butcher the
explanation but just kind of bear with
me here for a second because this is
important to understand why this works
and this is the most complex thing and
this is actually very useful you might
want to use this a lot like shifting
positions in a dictionary or in a list
okay so if I go back to my little
drawing thing here and I go like this
okay so let's create a grid over here
let's make it a few more rows this time
just for a better explanation so one two
three four okay I make it a four by four
okay do you guys can see my fancy
drawing skills let's make this a row so
let's say we have a row like this guy so
it's green make orange the orange didn't
work okay so green can stay there orange
like this like this and like this
and then we'll add some more colors
let's do like blue up here and up here
okay so obviously this is the row that
needs to be clear that my mouse going
over right now okay so this is the road
that needs to be clear what happens when
we clear this room okay so we've looked
from the bottom of the list up and we
found if we're looking at row like for
now looking at Row three and we say Row
three it needs to be clear okay so it's
cleared so we delete everything out of
Row three right this row is now gone so
our grid in memory just looks like this
and this so what we need to do now seem
to shift these position positions down
but we don't want to shift these
positions so that's why we're getting
that int so we know which position push
the positions in our grid to shift so we
delete that row and then what we're
doing is we're adding one and shifting
all these positions down okay that's the
straightforward example let's get rid of
this and let's do this okay so let's say
when we add our I don't know shape
whatever to our grid we end up getting
something that looks like this okay two
rows that need to be shifted down now
what we have to do is we have to delete
this row and this row now here's the
thing we delete this row we delete this
row how many rows does this now need to
move down well this needs to move down
to Rose so how do we know how many rows
to move this down how how many rows to
move everything else
above it down well that is based on our
what do you call it increment here and
that's why whenever we delete a row we
add one to increment because we know
that we have to now shifted down another
row okay and that's kind of the way that
this works if that makes sense
now the reason when we go through and we
look at things backwards so we don't
overwrite existing rows now this is
another complex thing okay
you probably don't have to really
understand this that much but anyways
okay so let's just it's not gonna let me
undo okay that's fine so we have this
right now here's the thing we started
looking at it from the top down to the
bottom what would happen is we would so
let's actually have to add another row
for this example to make sense okay so
if I add another row and I say well okay
mmm it's out of color
let's pick yellow all right let's say we
have a position here and we have a
position here alright so that means this
position this position and this position
I'll need to move down so here's the
thing if I move this one down by two
alright or if I move it down by one or
whatever it could possibly overwrite
this existing position and we don't want
that to happen so why why we have to
start looking at it from the bottom it's
that when we start moving everything
down we move the lowest most things down
first so that way when we then change
this there's no possible way we're gonna
overwrite this right here okay because
remember if you in a dictionary if you
change a key and the key already exists
well you're just gonna overwrite that
key so that's why we started looking at
it from the bottom if that doesn't make
sense don't worry just that's for any of
you that's why okay because I want to
make sure I explain everything and you
guys understand at least on some level
why I'm doing what I'm doing okay so
that's it for the explanation of clear
rows now let's call it function so when
are we gonna call clear rows now this is
actually an interesting call we could
call this function every loop but we're
only gonna call this when our change
piece hits the ground now the reason for
this
because you could possibly be moving
down the screen and at some point the
grid would have a full row before your
shape actually hit the ground now we
obviously know the way in Tetris when
you're moving down the grid until you
like lands or you stay static we're not
clearing anything so that's why we're
only gonna call this if we are about to
change the piece so clear rows
what does clear rows take again I'd say
it probably takes grid and locked
positions maybe yeah
grand and locked positions okay so path
of the grid will pass it lock positions
okay so then we're checking whenever
we're changing the piece if we should
clear a row and this can clear multiple
rows at once okay I'm gonna be showing
you guys a few different things so in
the last video I mentioned I was gonna
be doing more cosmetic stuff so that is
true in this video I'm gonna be showing
you how to do the main menu screen how
to draw text in the middle the screen
how to make things look a little bit
better and I'm also gonna be adding a
little bit of functionality to the game
in terms of making the piece fall faster
as it moves or as time moves forward so
obviously you want the game to get more
difficult as time goes on so what we're
gonna do to do that is increase the
speed at which the piece falls down the
screen it's pretty easy I'll show you
how to do that I'm going to be adding
score and we're gonna be displaying that
score and that's probably about it for
this game
so the first thing I want to show you is
how to add the piece following faster so
to do this we need to create a variable
in our main here and I'm just gonna make
this equal to what are we going to say
fall all right let's say level
underscore time okay and this is gonna
just represent how much time has passed
and it's gonna be similar to full time
and level is just because as we increase
speed like the level is going up kind of
whatever okay so say level time plus
equals clock dot get underscore wrong
time and we're gonna do exactly what we
did with making the piece move down the
screen except we're just gonna change
the speed at which it moves down the
screen so what I'm gonna do here is when
I make another if statement I'm just
simply going to say if level underscore
time divided by a thousand is greater
than and then you can put in whatever
time you want here now I'm gonna do five
seconds so every five seconds we
increase the speed okay
and then we can decide what we want to
increase the speed by so I'm going to
say a level underscore time we need to
first reset this back to zero so that we
continue to do this and then what I'm
gonna actually do here is gonna say if
level underscore time is greater than
and we want to put like a terminal
velocity here so at what speed do we
stop increasing the time because we
obviously we can't get to a negative
fall speed otherwise you're just gonna
instantly fall and we don't want it to
get too fast that the game's unplayable
so we need to pick a speed now a good
speed that I kind of found was 0.12
because anything faster than that is
like pretty fast but I mean you guys can
play with that and change that around
it's really easy number just to fix
right and then if we're greater than
that we're just simply gonna subtract a
value from level underscore time now
this value the magnitude to the size of
this value that you're subtracting is
gonna determine like how quickly you
increase the speed as well as obviously
the time so I put originally 0.01 and I
mean depending on how long it takes you
to play a Tetris game this is pretty
fast because that means after 50 seconds
you're already gonna be down to zero
point one seven which is very quick and
almost at terminal velocity so I
recommend you do 0.005 that means it'll
take about
a minute and 40 seconds before you're
gonna be close to reaching this terminal
velocity which might be good if you're
playing touches for a decent amount of
time okay so you guys can play with
those numbers but that is going to move
it down faster I would show you but it's
gonna take like a decent amount of time
for it to continue moving faster to just
play with that okay just trust me all
right the next thing we want to do is
add score so we need to first create a
score variable and as a score is equal
to zero like that and incrementing score
is pretty simple I'm gonna say and you
guys can make this whatever you want
whenever we clear a row I'm gonna add
ten to our score because you had ten
pieces or ten cubes or whatever that you
cleared okay
so actually the way that we need to do
this is we're gonna return a value from
clear rows which is gonna be equal to
score now I'm gonna go to clear rows and
in here I'm simply just gonna return i
NC okay
and I NC is the increment so how many
rows that we actually ended up clearing
so if we clear more than one row we're
gonna get a value of two we can multiply
that by whatever our score increments
gonna be and then yeah we can just add
that to the score so this is pretty
straightforward if we go to clear rows
we're gonna say score is equal to clear
rows multiplied by ten all right or
actually not equal to we're gonna have
to say plus equal to clear rows plus ten
now what we need to do is we need to
display this score on the screen
somewhere the user can see then we're
actually gonna save this score as well
when we lose the game okay so the way
that we can display this is we're gonna
have to do it in draw window but we're
gonna have to pass this score to draw
window so after our grid object we're
gonna pass score like that and we're
gonna go to draw window and we're simply
going to add another parameter here
score like that now I'm just gonna set
it equal to zero as a default parameter
so in case we call it somewhere else and
we forget to add that score that's fine
we don't need that so what I'm gonna do
now is I'm actually gonna go to draw
next shape and at draw next shape you
can see if I run the program quickly
here it shows us like a little text
object okay now I want to get this
similar text object so I'm just gonna
copy this fall into the label SX sy and
I'm just
bring it down here into draw window now
it doesn't really matter where you draw
it I'm just gonna plop it in the middle
here and obviously I'm gonna change this
from next shape to be score now we need
to obviously display what the actual
score is so we can just say a plus STR
score like that and that should be
displaying for us okay so now we have SX
and sy which is giving us the play area
I believe or no this is actually the
position in which we wanted to draw it
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
say wind dot blitz or is it surface
surface dog blitz
our text object which is D label and
then where do we want to draw it to and
draw SX sy now I'm just gonna have a
look up here to see where I did it here
so SX plus 10
sy minus 30 so what I might want to do
is we can add +10 to this so it's
aligned but then we're gonna subtract
we're actually add to the Y so it's
lower so I'm gonna add let's say like 80
like that so let's test this out and see
if it's working score so it's not low
enough so we'll add this I do 120 and
see where we're getting an escort again
not low enough
it's go 160 and again you guys can play
with these numbers score equals zero
perfect and then maybe we'll just add 10
more pixels here so it's more in the
center and you know whatever that's good
enough for me okay good
so that is working well so we've got the
score and we were moving down faster now
what else do we need to do what we need
to do now is work in main menu and
figure out what happens when we actually
lose the game so we have this check lost
and all this simply does is just quit
the game for us when that happens but we
want to do something else when we lose
and we want to display something to the
screen so actually before I go in main
menu I'm gonna go up here to a function
that I told you guys I need to get rid
of that that I was going to finish which
is draw a text in middle now this is
gonna take a service text and what else
do we want say size and color okay so
surface text size color this way you can
use this in another function or sorry
and another program and you can use it
multiple times with whatever text size
and color you want so we're gonna set up
a font trans a font
equals PI game dot font dot sys fonts by
now you probably know this I'm just
gonna pick Comic Sans we're gonna make
it equal to size and bold is gonna be
equal to true now you can make this
false if you want or just omit it
completely and then it won't make it
bold pretty straightforward make a label
label is equal to again phone dot render
and then we're gonna say text one for
anti-aliasing and color like this okay
now we'll just simply draw this in the
middle of the screen so to do this will
say surface double its label comma and
now we're gonna do a little bit of math
here so talk underscore left under short
X plus play underscore width divided by
2 not 3 minus and we're gonna get the
label width and the way we do this I
don't believe I've actually done this
yet is get underscore width I think I'm
just gonna check yeah get width and then
the reason I have this in brackets
because I'm gonna divide this by 2 as
well and this will essentially give us
the middle position where we should be
drawing in terms of x-coordinate okay so
now I'm gonna give top underscore left y
plus play underscore height divide it by
2
okay and now same thing - label dot get
underscore height in brackets and
divided by 2 I don't know why kids tab
over here okay
/ - and that should hopefully be working
for us okay so we can test that in just
a second so we've got this it's bleeding
now whatever text we want to the screen
so this makes it really easy for us to
draw anything to the middle of the
screen so the first thing I want to draw
it to the middle of the screen is like a
you lost message so when it says you've
lost what I want to do is draw obviously
you lost and tell them that so let's say
draw text middle and then what do we
want to draw well let's simply draw what
surface first actually that we need so
we'll say win and then we're going to
pass it text and in this case we're
gonna say you lost exclamation point
sighs let's go
or a and color let's go wait and you
obviously you guys can play around that
now after I draw that and I display the
screen or update this screen PI games
display update just because we haven't
called the window yet draw window when
we do this then what we're gonna do is
we're just gonna delay so whereas a PI
game dot time delay and I'm just gonna
delay one and a half seconds just so
once this comes up the user has a second
to look at it because then we're gonna
move back into our main menu screen
which you'll see okay so I'm just gonna
fast forward this until I lose and then
you guys can see that it's working and
there we go so we got you lost and then
it's late and then just quit because I
have this PI game dot displayed up quick
here okay so now we're gonna move to is
main menu everything else is working I
told you guys it's not like super
difficult all this stuff and in main
menu what we're gonna do now is we're
just gonna make it pop up whenever you
start the game and whatever you lose and
just gonna say hit any key to like move
forward to continue okay so I'm just
gonna use up another game loop in here
so we're gonna say run it was true well
run and this is gonna be really similar
to the loop we've done above it's just
up just a lot shorter we're and we're
gonna just draw in here without using a
different function just because we're
not drawing very much so it's not
important that we wouldn't call it like
update the screen with a defined
function so I'm just gonna fill with
block just we kind of are getting rid of
everything we're gonna draw text middle
and what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna
say press any key to play okay and then
we'll give this a size of 60 and a color
of white once again okay so that's being
drawn in the middle will update the
display so pi end up display dot update
like that
and then we're gonna say for event and
PI game dot event type gets a similar to
what we've already typed up top we're
gonna say if event type equals equals PI
game dot quit we always want one of
these not quick cue then we are simply
going to say run
oops run is equal to false and then we
can tap out here and we can just make
sure that we are actually quitting the
display so don't quit and we'll get rid
of this pygame dot display dot quit and
then we're gonna add one more event and
this event is gonna be a key down so
whenever they press any key on the
keyboard
then that is going to move this forward
and we're simply gonna call this main
function where we'll play and I'll
explain how this kind of flows in just a
second because it's really nice okay so
if event dot type equals equals PI game
dot all capitals key down so if they hit
any key then what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say main like that okay and
I believe that is about it okay
yeah so let's see here pi game dot
display dot quit looks correct okay so
the way this is gonna work pretty much
is when we run the game we start by
running main menu so we run main menu
and then we could go into this main loop
where all its gonna do is just say press
any key to play and that's gonna be
drawn in the middle of the screen once
that happens we're gonna check if
they're hitting any key if they hit any
key we're gonna call main in which case
sir let me close this so it's easier to
see if we hit main then we go into the
main game loop and we go and we do this
loop until eventually we lose once we
lose it displays you lost on the screen
makes this loop equal to false which
means it brings us back into this main
menu loop and we can play again by
hitting any key pretty straightforward
okay so let's test this out to make sure
this is working draw text missing one
potential argument color ah because I
didn't give a surface my bad so let's
just do win and there we go okay so
press any key to play press space
missing one protect mate okay sorry guys
and this is why we test our perfect okay
win and now let's try there we go
and now we're playing it shows the score
and you guys can mess around it I
haven't actually tested the score so
I'll just do this really quickly and see
if I can clear row without having to
fast forward which we may be able to do
not use it
okay let's see there you go and score is
equal to 10 so the score systems working
as well and that's relief because I
hadn't even tested that before I put
this in the video okay perfect
oh when you press the X brings you to
press any key to play you press it again
you can do that so if we wanted to
change it so when you hit the X key and
the main thing and you want to close the
game then in the main loop here sorry
what are you gonna do is sort of saying
run equals false just to high game
display dot quit so you can do both you
and say run equals false and then you
can quit the display as well okay so
what's next so I said we were going to
save the score and potentially display
that so if we want to save the score
we're gonna have to do something when we
lose so we're gonna have to update like
the current score and we're gonna use a
text file to do this so that you can
play multiple times so what I'm gonna do
now say new file just create a new text
file and it's gonna call this scores dot
txt okay and here I'm just gonna put a
zero as a default value it's really
important you put a default value to
start otherwise you might run into some
issues so just create a new text file
make sure it's in your directory with
the main with the script okay now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create another
function doesn't really matter where it
goes so I'm gonna say define update
underscore score and we're gonna give it
to score okay now in here what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna say with open and this
is how we're gonna open our text file
and it's like update and display with
open scores text in our so in read mode
and this action needs to be in quotation
marks as well we are going to say F yeah
I have to do this as F sorry I say F dot
read lines like this okay and that'll be
equal to lines is equal to F dot read
lines so that means our score is going
to be well the first line so score is
equal to lines zero and we're gonna add
this dot strip so that we remove any
like backslash ends because if you don't
know in a text file when you hit the
next line the way that it actually
tracks that you have another line is it
puts a character that looks like this on
the line it's invisible to you in the
text file when you're viewing it but
when you read it in with code you
actually read in this character
we just want to make sure we strip that
off in case it is there I'm gonna say
square equals this and then we'll just
say okay so we've done that and since
we're topping out now at all it's gonna
automatically close our file what we're
gonna do now is we are going to open the
file again except in this time we're
going to open it right mode which means
we're gonna overwrite whatever is in the
file and we're simply gonna say if score
is I guess I'm gonna change this to end
score standing for new score if score is
greater than n score then we'll say F
dot and we'll say write lines actually
right I think and we'll simply put in
STR of score which is this updated score
otherwise so if that's not true we just
have to write back the other score
because we're clearing it when we open
this with W mode okay so rinse it F dot
right and then sorry this is gonna be
what am i doing N and score yeah sorry
so I kind of messed up in this way it
should be the other way around but
whatever we're just checking if the
original score is greater than the new
score if it is we'll write the original
score otherwise we'll write the new
score so this works still it just not
the way that I was thinking about it
when I was kind of talking about that
okay so update score should work and
then you know you can actually returned
let's just return actually a naught we
don't need to return anything so I
haven't pre-written this yet so I'm kind
of still just going through how I want
it to work okay what we'll do here after
we start round equal to false we'll say
update score and we'll give it whatever
the current score is and then this
should be working in the scores dot txt
file so let's run this I'll fast forward
through and make sure things working
[Music]
okay so we got here not support it
between instance of string and int okay
so if score greater than end stress
which mean we have to convert the
student int so if we go back up to score
and where did I make this okay
score is going to be int score like that
okay and that's hopefully work because
score comes in as an int and we'll run
it one more time one more fast forward
sorry without guys okay and another
issue lines zero Linda
list index range okay I'm gonna have a
look at this and come back okay so this
code is actually working just fine the
issue was that since the last time when
I crashed we didn't end up writing
anything into the file so we had a blank
file and then we were going lines to
zero where is it here and obviously
there was no line 0 so that crashed but
if you just add any numbers so if I add
0 back in here two squares dot txt and
save it then this works fine okay so
that's it for saving scores now we need
to display those saved scores so I'm
kind of gonna leave this up to you guys
where you want to display it I don't
really know where I want to put my saved
score like high score maybe on the left
side of the screen doesn't really matter
so if I want to draw it on the left side
of the screen then I can do something
like we're gonna have to first get this
max score right so I'm gonna have to
make a new function called define max
score or last score or whatever you want
to call it and if you call max score
what we're gonna do is we're just gonna
do the exact same thing we did here so
we can say it with open square set text
score 0 epsilon 0 dot strip accepting
this time we're gonna return score like
that okay now we actually do here to is
we could just simply replace this whole
line with max score and just say score
equals max score be the efficient way to
do it and I mean feel free to do that if
you want or leave it the other way okay
so now we have something that's getting
us max score so how we gonna use this
well when we call main
I guess when we call me or we can call
main menu does it like you guys if you
want to draw it in the main menu can do
that otherwise draw it in the main to
draw it in the main all you're gonna do
is gonna say like last score is equal to
u max score which is gonna be whatever
is stored in that text file and then to
draw this well we're gonna have to pass
this again into when we're redrawing
window so in draw window I'm just gonna
say last score we can go up to draw
window again say last underscore score
equal to zero and you're pretty much it
gonna copy exactly what we have here
with this font and the split so let me
just comment this and say this is
current score just so I could remember
you know how to comment and say loss
score or high score whatever you want to
say here and then we can just say score
and we actually get rid of this font
because we already defined it
we'll say high score equals and in this
case last underscore score okay
draw that to the screen this is probably
not where you want to draw it you
probably want to draw it top left X
minus like some value minus 30 top left
Y maybe plus I don't know like 300 or
something so now we can see where this
is actually gonna draw if we check this
out so let's run this press any key so
it's not obviously showing up where we
want to so we have to subtract more from
this so let's subtract like I don't know
100 and then this was plus too much
let's do plus 200 and high score so
again like you got to move it over more
so we'll move over 200 this time and
hopefully this works
okay so high score zero scores here and
that's obviously because at the current
moment we have no our score is just zero
in that text file okay so I think that
is pretty much it for this video if you
guys have any questions any errors
anything that I did in this video that
you weren't sure about leave a comment
down below we'll be sure to get back to
you